[Music]
With a sample write Sapp sr Ju3 1
Daddy's ice should be good
ds I heard the line like tom's n3
No.5
Chae Sui shirt Dr. Laughter Finally installed
Bertie my a
Annan os Bells sauce The
left side goes to the cam
[Music
] Ristal  All the words are big Jo Sensation
Carmel Camp House Websak India
[Music]
Ah
Ali Lee Seung-gi didn't exist Just a general
clause had a name and a degree, but
now the name is Yang
Ye-min Most of the stories here are in front of Shinsegae Department Store Chun
-gang  It's a cheese hot dog.
I sliced ​​the pickled vegetables and sat in the
cart
for 5 minutes.
A little bit of Jade's team
came out, and I tried to embroider it. It's very tasty.
I don’t know, each of them
was made in Korea. Did you eat a lot of them?
South inside, located in the world
, only a lot of magnets, ceramics, runners, kimchi,
and
rice.
Selling it ah
it's not so fast so don't think of it as a core uh uh uh uh uh uh uh
uh uh a little song comfortably try the contents
just try it ah uh uh uh uh the
app puts together bo finding north nax
ouk
msr which market in our working class, Lee Young-
yu lost
My name is Yunjin Park, and my name is Park Yun-jin.
The name of our store is Haeram Sang, Namgajwa-
do Warren's Market, Seodaemun-gu, Seoul
. It has been 32 years since I operated it
.
doesn't come in at all,
but only fish  Just grind raw color, haha,
garlic, carrots, and just a little flour,
so knead in the mixture
to match the ingredients for fish cake. If you put it in oil and
read it, it will be possible for consumers to scoop out and serve it.
I don't
lose I want to
go out to save the authentic taste Break this ring
- web Gen Yudai
4 Simple breakfast together I have
another idea that money will be enough
I've been here for
31 years Coffee and Tea School 6
Episode 1 Still Maya That's
it  I have to sell coffee, vegetables, and crab
meat.
I have to sell
lala toast with cheese.
It's water and vegetables are thin
, and if you give it coffee or milk or whatever it's fun for,
I thought it would be enough for an inspirational meal
.  Grave Wan
bar, but not the
last company, big second
5 uh oh,
our food is a combination bar,
delicious egg grab ak
[Music]
Ah, at first, put it in the middle of the
middle, then put it in the middle, then put it together,
then make it
with commotion and Buddhism.
Hey, hey,
it dries right away. What does this say
? Look at it and adjust the light.
[Applause]
[Music]
Solo 2 Order me 2 ramen for our meal. I
'm happy
[Music
] Uh
[Music]